pendant que vous avez des images en
direct à kiev est manifestement donc le
tout ne se calme pas et ces images qui
font évidemment à réagir tous les
écrivains de la planète est évidemment
ceux de montréal également anne louise
despatie en a rencontré un certain
nombre
à la caisse populaire ukrainienne de
heureusement la nuit a été courte pour
plusieurs employés qui ont suivi ce qui
se passe à kiev
parce qu'il nous blesse vraiment au
coeur c'est que ce sont entre les jeux
crinière c'est très émouvant un moment
surtout qu est en fait c'est la guerre
sur la shoah lui comme moi elle ne
pensait pas que la crise qui dure depuis
trois mois
mènerait recettes répression contre les
milliers de manifestants opposés au
président les gens veulent que le
président quitte notre gouvernement nos
autorités
ils méprisent le peuple il néglige
complètement le pignon public
le président ne coûte pas notre peuple
plutôt du taux de taux il y à plus de
20000 montréalais d'origine ukrainienne
les premiers immigrants se sont
installés dans pointe saint charles à la
fin des années 1800 puis plusieurs se
sont retrouvés dans heureusement on y
trouve maintenant trois églises
catholique et orthodoxe et plusieurs
commerces
partout il n'y est question que des
événements sanglants de kiev
la question est que nous sommes pour la
démocratie ne sont pour une société
libre à nos sociétés tolérant pour
l'historien romain zerbine la communauté
ukrainienne de montréal est plutôt
contre le président ianoukovitch et il
ya déjà au moins 25 morts
et tout ça c'est sur la conscience du
dictateur et on voudrait côté parts
avant la fin de l'ue jusqu'en 2015
tous ceux que nous avons rencontrés
souhaite que la communauté
internationale exercent des pressions
contre les régimes pour qu'il y ait des
élections anticipées
ici anne louise despatie radio canada
montréal